hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
very early on in his work the Poetics
Aristotle is going to make a very
important distinction that helps us
separate out the different kinds of
poetic mimesis and he's going to tell us
that you know we have epic and tragic
poetry comedy dither realm music both
for the flute and the liar and that all
of these are types of mimesis now
they're not the only types of mimosas
he'll also talk about painting but the
we're concerned with the ones that
incorporate music meter the sorts of
things that fall over on one side as
opposed to what we could call typically
the plastic art so paintings sculpture
things where you're representing
primarily
visually and so he's going to say that
we can distinguish these from each other
there are all kinds of mimosas right so
they have that in common we can
distinguish them in three different
respects three different ways and what
are these well so there's the media the
objects and the modes and these are
translations which you know they're
decent translations they could be a
little bit misleading so they each
require a bit of explanation so you
notice that in the Greek he uses this um
hetero right this is this means other or
different from
so we've got different media uh the toe
n what what the thing is in what the
representation or imitation well that's
what we translate mimesis is what it's
being conveyed in
um later on he'll call this n hoist and
that just means in what right so we'll
come back to that in a moment and then
we have the different objects
right so the the a ending on that
indicates that we're talking about stuff
and so different kinds of things that
are being represented or imitated in the
composition and then we have uh so
that's in Greek just ha and then we have
different modes and mode that could mean
a lot of different things
um here is we're going directly to the
Greek might be a little bit Illuminating
So to heteros that ending us is very
important and the hosts the
how right so when we're thinking about
modes we're thinking about how the media
is actually being used effectively to
produce the mimesis the imitation the
representation
and he's going to discuss each of these
in turn in a bit more detail so he'll
tell us that the media includes three
main aspects Rhythm which is just a
transliteration of Ruth most right the
Greek word for that and then something
that we can translate is Melody or even
more literally as song Melos so there's
a musical aspect or element to this part
of mimesis and then we have meter now
meter is how things come out in time
right so for example in aristophanese
comedy the frogs it's one of the little
lines that I do remember from uh back
when I was first learning ancient Greek
the frogs themselves are croaking right
and so he makes up some some uh words
with this and it goes
coax right so that that
is a meter and the Greeks had all sorts
of meters and actually this is very
common in both Greek and Latin poetry in
the ancient world and we still use it to
some degree today if you think about uh
spoken word poetry or hip-hop and rap
lyrics when somebody is engaging in that
there's a certain kind of
that's a meter right so all of these
things come together
in the different sorts of uh media that
are that are offered and he gives you
some examples of this
he tells us that
um
uh you know we we can have some Arts
that use all of these media like
dithiram and tragedy and comedy others
don't use all of them and it's not
enough to have
the this media
to be a imitation and he uses a great
example here so he talks about Homer
right Homer is an epic poet most famous
for The Iliad and the Odyssey using
these these different elements and then
he talks about empedocles now in
pedicles is what we would call a natural
philosopher but a lot of the earlier
philosophers wrote in poetry and he says
that we should actually call him a
natural scientist a fousey fusio logon
rather than a poet and then he brings up
one other really interesting example if
someone should produce mimesis in a
medley of all of the meters and he
brings up this guy kairamon composing a
centaur a hybrid Rhapsody containing all
the meters it's still it's still poetry
right now what about in tragedy so
when we get down to tragedy specifically
the media that we're really paying
attention to there are six elements or
we could call them Dimensions whatever
you want to call them parts of tragedy
and two of them are in the media so
diction Lexus what is being said and how
it's being said right
um the way in which you're you're
articulating things and then what it
calls lyric poetry Melo poya
this is the medium or media the two
together in which tragedy takes place
and you know so when you're reading a
Greek tragedy you may not notice this as
you're reading it in Translation and
it's a little bit different when it's
actually up on the stage right the Lexus
of the actors plays a role do they
Mumble a lot do they articulate well so
that's that's one key aspect and then we
have a much broader range of the objects
the things the matters that are actually
being represented through mimesis and
this allows us to differentiate things
as well so you know some some types of
imitation don't necessarily use all of
these some do we can say the same thing
about the object objects in general the
objects are people in action prachontas
doing something although we can also
extend this to people suffering as we're
going to see is a very important thing
in in tragedy and we could even say with
like lyric poetry if there's a love poem
Oh I love you so much I miss you so much
right well that's a kind of suffering as
well but we could roll that all under
what people do and what happens to them
and he says that we look at people who
are either better than us in general
or worse than us in general
and this helps differentiate things too
so like tragedy for example at least the
main characters are typically people who
are of a higher more elevated status
greater than the average person who is
The Spectator for it comedy tends to be
about screw-ups people who are lower in
not necessarily class but certainly in
their moral qualities right and now he
says at one point they're typically not
the worst right they're not totally
vicious but they do tend to be bad
people all right or we could have
representation of people on our own
level and that differentiates
these types of
you know mimetic Arts and their products
from each other
um in tragedy three of the most
important elements of tragedy have to do
with the objects what is being
represented so
by far for Aristotle the most important
thing is what we call plot and what he
calls muthos which you know you can use
the word myth to render that as a cognit
but it's really more story right
myths the way that we think of them are
a particular kind of story right and so
stories narratives in general are what
are being presented in the narrative and
then we also have character ethos now we
tend to think of character as well this
person is this character like you know
it's an action movie Arnold
Schwarzenegger is playing this guy right
or in a rom-com this actor and this
actress are playing these people over
here what Aristotle means is not the one
single person the you know
um individual but rather the character
that that individual has so are they in
general are they a good person or a bad
person are they given to impatience are
they thoughtful we could go on and on
and on so these are generic traits which
then find themselves uh in particular
individuals I almost said unified but
sometimes they're not sometimes
characters can have different qualities
that are almost at war with each other
and so that's something that's being
depicted in tragedy as well and then
thought the annoya what it is that
people think about things but even more
their motivations the reasons why they
are making the choices to engage in the
actions or take the positions or adopt a
certain Viewpoint that they are in the
play so they explain themselves and
notice how some of these kind of go
together right how do people actually
explain themselves well by talking or or
singing right so
they show their character and what they
do but also in why they do it and all of
this feeds into the plot finally we have
the mode and this can take a lot of
different forms how in fact does the
poet the person who is writing the Epic
the tragedy the ditherram pick whatever
else it is how in fact do they carry
this out so one way is by narration
right so by announcing things to people
um personation uh basically you know how
things play out right and he says that
Homer does both of these so how should
we make sense of that if you've ever
read Homer
there's parts of Homer where he is just
telling the story right and then
Achilles you know was angry at Agamemnon
uh with with this this fierceness in his
heart he's about to draw his sword
thinking I should kill this man where he
stands right that's somebody talking
about Achilles telling us what's going
on in his head and then Achilles
actually speaks right oh Agamemnon
you're a crappy King now this is not how
uh Homer says it is much more elevated
language but um that's part of what's
going on there and then Athena shows up
and she's like Achilles don't kill him
uh that would be a terrible idea right
that's the character speaking for
themselves that's personation and then
we also have
enactment
um prachontas
like doing things now in
um somebody like Homer
there isn't this aspect of the doing
things the doing is being related or
told in the narrative but in tragedy
up on the stage at least with some of
the things that are being done some of
the action often happens off stage
people are doing things people are
moving around the stage
people are getting in each other's faces
or you know matters like that and so in
tragedy Aristotle is going to tell us
that the way in which this takes place
is through what we translate as
spectacle opsis in Greek the stuff that
we actually see on the stage and so this
would be you know the actors themselves
moving around with their masks doing
their grand gestures all of that is part
of the mode so you know this allows us
not only to classify in general what's
what's actually going on in the mesas
but to differentiate
not only these different uh
areas or Dimensions but to differentiate
the different types of poetic production
which includes musical performances
right but is particularly centered on
what we typically call poetry epic uh
tragic comedic and and other poetry in
which people are in fact carrying
something out in a medium representing
certain objects and doing so in a
certain mode so this is some
distinctions that Aristotle is making
very early on that I think can be quite
helpful for wrapping our head around his
view on the different sorts of mimetic
or poetic Productions that we encounter
in ancient Greek culture